- NOW, FATHER, SINCE YOU'VE
RETURNED TO THE CIVILIZED WORLD,
IT'S CRUCIAL
THAT YOU LEARN THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A SALAD FORK
AND A DESSERT FORK.
- [chomping]
- NO, NO, NO.
SALAD FORK.
- HMM?
[grunts]
- [groans]
[gasping]
- WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
ARMANDO, THESE ARE PEOPLE TRYING
TO HAVE A NICE MEAL.
WHY YOU BOTHER THEM?
- [gasps]
- ALLOW ME TO APOLOGIZE
ON ARMANDO'S BEHALF.
HE IS NEW,
BUT HE IS VERY GOOD BOY.
- [gasps]
- ARMANDO, UH,
WHY DON'T YOU GO
AND GET THESE NICE PEOPLE
SOME FREE BREADSTICKS?
- [gasps]
- YOU COME BACK ANYTIME.
ANYBODY YOU WANNA
STAB HIM IN THE NECK,
YOU GO RIGHT AHEAD.
[upbeat music]
♪
- [crunches]
[camera shutter clicking]
[mechanical arm whirring]
- [grunts]
- YIPPEE!
[shrieks]
AAH! AAH!
[screaming]
[growls]